[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de t&d
78 nous sommes le mercredi 1er juin
voici les titres
jean luc mélenchon attrape hier le
leader de la france insoumise est venu
soutenir son candidat nuxe où il ya
martin est dans la 12e circonscription
des yvelines pour les législatives il a
rencontré les professeurs et parents
d'élèves des collèges youri gagarine et
gustave courbet concernés par une baisse
des moyens pour la rentrée prochaine le
6 litres revient le 23e championnat
inter collèges des matchs
d'improvisation théâtrale se tient
vendredi à la merise attrape après
plusieurs tournois de qualification
quatre établissements saint quentinois
se retrouvent pour les demi finales et
la finale de l'événement organisé par
déclic théâtre en france au rendez vous
sportif faisait sa rentrée après
plusieurs années d'absence le gala du
boxing club de saint quentin en yvelines
étaient au programme samedi dernier
c'est au complexe sportif de l'europe la
team farrugia vais a prévu une quinzaine
de combats et le public était au rendez
vous mais avant de développer ces titres
le choca à versailles à un gendarme des
yvelines de 49 ans s'est donné la mort
hier mardi sur son lieu de travail avec
son arme de fonctions membre de
l'escadron départemental de sécurité
routière
l'homme laisse sa compagne et deux
filles âgés de 21 et 16 ans une cagnotte
en ligne a été mise en service par le
site de la fondation de la maison de la
gendarmerie pour venir en aide à sa
famille le lien qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran il s'agit du deuxième suicide
dans la gendarmerie en moins de 24
heures une gendarme de vendée a
également mis fin à ses jours hier
[Musique]
le dans l'actualité de ce mercredi des
assises du numérique elle se tenait ce
mercredi donc aux pyramides de port
marly une un événement qui revenait
après une dernière édition en 2020
s'était organisé par l'opérateur ceneri
numérique chargé de développer les
services numériques des territoires des
hauts-de-seine et des yvelines notamment
le déploiement du très haut débit une
journée de tables rondes et d'ateliers
sur le numérique pour l'éducation les
territoires et les bâtiments connectés
la e-santé la cybersécurité écouter ses
propos recueillis sur place par mathilde
au front quand la seconde édition des
assises du numérique cette importance
est à un moment important pour les
villes les élus est également le
partenaire de pouvoir se rencontrer et
présenter les différentes
options que propose sony numérique 1 c à
ses usagers adhérents donc on est sur la
cybersécurité on est sur la santé bref
on est sur le numérique au sein des
collectivités et dans l'optique d'un
service public de meilleure qualité donc
à la fois des partenaires des élus des
politiques y sont présents voilà tout le
monde se rencontre avec des ateliers
mais après si chacun peut choisir le
thème qui l'intéressent nous sommes
aujourd'hui déterminer puisque nous
avons fait des économies substantielles
sur le déploiement du réseau nous avons
créé le réseau fibre dans les yvelines
il ya de la fibre partout on a économisé
120 millions d'euros comme ça on les
réinvestit dans un système de tablettes
numériques individuel pour tous les
collégiens et nous allons donc avoir
dans tous les collèges des yvelines dans
quatre ans ce sera déployé pour chaque
collégien cet outil numérique individuel
nous serons là encore le premier
département de france a donné cet atout
à ses enfants il convient donc lui
largement sur ces assises du numérique
dans notre édition de demain jeudi
dans ce set 8 journal
[Musique]
je vous en parlais dans les titres jean
luc mélenchon était attrape ce mardi le
leader de la france insoumise a
rencontrée à cette occasion william
martin est le candidat de nuxe la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale dans la 11e circonscription des
yvelines et miquel et demi d'euros a
suivi ce déplacement
il est arrivé comme une rock star jean
luc mélenchon le fondateur de la france
insoumise était à traves ce mardi 31 mai
l'homme politique est venu à la
rencontre de jeunes devant le collège
courbet dans le cadre de la campagne des
élections législatives quand ils vous
voir en vrai tu vois c'est entre spider
man et puis père noël même si je ne
gagne pas une élection même si de toute
façon j'aurais servi à quelque chose ils
auront vu un homme politique venir dans
leur coin qui est connu leur dire des
mots aimables et puis parler de l'école
en dit jean jé notre famille tout ça moi
j'ai besoin de le dire et de le
transmettre au total ils étaient plus de
300 personnes devant le collège
trappistes dans la foule des professeurs
d'école d éducateur spécialisé en
protection de l'enfance encore des
curieux franchement on est content que
voilà tout le monde est unique ça c'est
un message de rassemblement a pour toute
la gauche et on est content que
mélenchon et soit là je le suis depuis
2008 et je vois deux pour lui depuis
2012 donc c'est spécial de le voir en
vrai c'est
c'est je veux dire y'a pas de mots dans
le dictionnaire pour dire ce que ça que
ça fait mais en tout cas
je suis convaincue que
c'est la personnalité numéro 1
d'histoire de france parce que c'est
celui qui a tient le combat le plus
noble un bon coup de pouce pour williams
martinez le candidat de la nouvelle
union populaire écologique et sociale de
la 11e circonscription des yvelines un
territoire où il apparaît favori le 12
juin prochain est typiquement une
circonscription qu'on peut on va faire
basculer dans le camp de la nouvelle
union populaire à une seule condition il
faut que notre électorat se mobilisent
que les gens comprennent que la bataille
continue en 2017 la france insoumise
avait terminé en quatrième position dans
la 11e circonscription des yvelines avec
8 65% des suffrages au premier tour
aujourd'hui l'alliance nuxe espère
remporter ce territoire on reste dans la
11e circonscription des yvelines
jusqu'au 12 juin date du premier tour
des élections législatives tv 78 vous
aide à y voir plus clair sur les enjeux
dans chacune des 12 circonscription des
yvelines pour parler de la 11e
circonscription nicolas d'ombré est avec
moi plateau bonsoir bonsoir et y aurait
de la rédaction de thé des 78 ton
l'entendait dans le sujet précédent sur
nuxe nicolas à nuque justement pour l
emporter dans cette circonscription en
fait le candidat dit ça parce que si on
regarde les résultats du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle de cette année
est bien jean-luc mélenchon arrive en
tête dans la 11e circonscription des
yvelines avec 33% des voix suivi des
manuels macron avec plus de 28% des
suffrages et si on regarde plus près
dans certaines communes de la
circonscription attrape le candidat de
la france insoumise dépasse les 60% à la
verrière les 50% et comme vous l'avez vu
dans le sujet la candidature de la nuque
et porté par williams martinez et donc
comme il le dit ce qui sera déterminant
c'est la participation trappe la
verrière voici deux des communes de
cette 11e circonscription mais il y en a
d'autres annonces elles sont viables à
verrières on retrouve les communes
d'elancourt de saint cyr l'école de bois
d'arcy de fontenay-le-fleury et du
mesnil-saint-denis alors un peu
d'histoire ce territoire a connu
différentes bascule de la droite à la
gauche avec fit plusieurs figures le
lieu politiques locales élues à
l'assemblée nationale qui sont justement
ces figures politiques locales alors
c'est notamment le cas de l'ancien maire
art de trappes socialiste guy malandain
députés entre 1981 et 1993 en 1993 la
circonscription bascule à droite avec le
maire d'elancourt jean michel fourgous
jusqu'en 1997 puis vous savez il ya un
épisode avec la dissolution de
l'assemblée nationale décidée par le
président à blick jacques chirac eh bien
c'est la socialiste catherine tasca qui
remporte le scrutin un siège qu'elle
cédera de nouveau en 2002 à jean michel
fourgous pendant dix ans la droite
conservera ce territoire puis en 2012
suite à l'élection de françois hollande
la circonscription re bascule à gauche
avec benoît hamon jusqu'en 2017 après la
victoire d'emmanuel maquereau en 2017 la
vague en marche passe aussi par la 11e
circonscription des yvelines c'est nadia
et candidates issues de la société
civile qui l'emportent
nommé ministre en 2020 elle est
contrainte de démissionner de son siège
à l'assemblée nationale une élection
législative partielle est donc organisé
en septembre 2020 et là c'est le
candidat les républicains philippe
benassaya qui l'emportent devant la
candidate de la gauche sandrine gang
avec 57% des voix alors depuis l'ancien
maire de bois d'arcy à la sièges à
l'assemblée nationale il apporter
notamment plusieurs propositions sur les
questions de la sécurité et pour ces
élections législatives à venir il sera
candidat pour l'union de la droite et du
centre dans une 11e circonscription l'a
compris eu différents basculement de
droite à gauche de gauche à droite là
philippe benassaya le député de la
droite qui est sortant sera candidat
nouveau qu'y aura-t-il face à lui ce
alors pour la majorité présidentielle
aurélie pierre senza défendra le projet
d' emmanuel macron et du gouvernement
des lettres d'elisabeth porn autres
candidatures à gauche en marche en marge
pardon de la nile tv patrick planque
défendra les positions de lutte ouvrière
dans le camp des souverainistes et des
nationalistes le rassemblement national
sera représentée par sophie chabanais
alexandre michel arnaud portera les
couleurs de reconquête et olivier
galland ce sera le parti de nicolas
dupont aignan debout la france puis
plusieurs mouvements politiques seront
représentés pour le scrutin des
législatives dans la 11e circonscription
c'est le cas notamment de l'union des
démocrates musulmans avec raouf maïza le
parti animal y sera porté par christophe
aubin jean-luc tramoni portera l'union
des centristes et des écologistes et
enfin aymeric de la fosse le parti
pirate merci nicolas pour toutes ces
précisions sur la 11e circonscription
des yvelines on continue dans ses
éditions du journal également dans
l'émission 7 8 week-end de vendredi nos
tour d'horizon sur ces circonscriptions
à venir demain dans le journal un focus
sur la 10e circonscription des yvelines
c'est cette circonscription est du sud
yvelines et je vous rappelle les dates
de ces élections législatives le 12 juin
pour le premier tour et le 19 juin pour
le deuxième tour
[Musique]
ce nouveau service à maurepas une bande
de téléconsultations médicales a été
installé à l'espace solidarité square de
la marche elle a été mise en fonction ce
mercredi par la ville pour répondre à la
pénurie de praticiens dans la commune en
10 15 minutes vous pourrez entrer en
contact avec un médecin généraliste des
instruments de mesure sont disponibles
sur l'appareil un thermomètre c'était au
scope tensiomètre une ordonnance et un
compte rendu médical sont ensuite
directement imprimé sur la bande le prix
est le même que celui d'une consultation
conventionnée de secteur 1 avec tiers
payant l'accès se fait du lundi au
samedi sur les horaires d'ouverture de
l'espace solidarité des agents d'accueil
peuvent vous accompagner lors de votre
venue c'est le retour du ciq mythe le
championnat inter collèges de match
d'improvisation théâtrale organisée par
déclic théâtre se déroulera ce vendredi
à la merise attrape quatre collèges
saint quentinois sont encore en lice
pour la victoire après des dizaines
d'ateliers au cours de l'année ils vont
pouvoir enfin s'affronter lors de
plusieurs matchs les précisions de
céline charles
faux faux
copé
beaucoup
au fond
kung fu
beaucoup souffrent
beaucoup
au bout
[Musique]
dufour 6 avant je
n'oublierai jamais cette histoire je
préfère toujours ma vache pas fermes et
cette vie c'est créer un espace de
rigolade et un est un espace de liberté
où en fait les
les enfants vont pouvoir s'exprimer
aussi dans l'enceinte de l'établissement
ou sur scène alors une parole qui va
être cadré par la fonction de larvik
notamment avec l'accompagnement des
couteaux
[Musique]
quand
on va accueillir les élèves dès 18
heures à la mairie ils vont pouvoir se
rencontrer sans traîner un petit peu
s'échauffer découvrir la salle aussi
parce que c'est la première fois de
l'année qu'ils vont jouer dans une salle
aussi importante est vaste que la merise
[Musique]
et puis ça fait cela faisait plusieurs
années qu'un tel événement n'était plus
organiser le boxing club de saint
quentin en yvelines accueille samedi
dernier un grand gala de boxe anglaise
de niveau national retour sur cet
événement avec bixente n'a rien senti
steban
[Musique]
c'était l'occasion de donner aux jeunes
leur premier round après plusieurs
années dans l'ombre le boxing club de
saint quentin en yvelines revient sous
le feu des projecteurs avec un gala de
boxe anglaise c'est agréable ça fait pas
rien de fermer notre sport et caetera et
c'est une bonne occasion des personnes
et surtout que les 100 premiers comme
annoncé en fait le fait du conte en
échange comme c'est important on a aussi
dit potentiel ici en france on a des
jeunes qui ont la possibilité de monter
donc on est là aussi pour les soutenir
et puis voilà pour les 28 points au
total une quinzaine de combats avec des
yvelinois et leurs adversaires venus
d'ile-de-france du grand est de bretagne
le public était au rendez vous on a
toujours fait le plein et
j'espère que ça va durer et qu'on va
relancer la boxe professionnelle aussi
parce que chez nous on a beaucoup de
boxe pro et on espère repartir sur la
vox populi ne sont pas montés sur le
ring mais étaient présents pour soutenir
leur club formateur les grands noms de
la team farrugia on à marvin petit qui
doit faire un championnat d'europe
adila qui reprend la boxe il ya comme on
appelle ça on a on a on a des
opportunités j'en ai deux qui sont pas
pour la france ils sont pour la moldavie
mais qui peuvent faire les jeux
olympiques messi de retour je suis de
retour sur le chemin
et le retour à sa très mal fort de ce
grand retour le boxing club de saint
quentin en yvelines soit très réitérer
ce type d'événement deux à trois fois
par an
[Musique]
voilà c'est déjà la fin de ce journal
merci de votre fidélité nouvelle édition
à retrouver demain jeudi sur notre
antenne belle soirée et sur tv 78
[Musique]